NOT A PHONY WITCH HUNT SENT
AROUND A NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HERE WITH THE REACTION TO THIS
AND ALSO BIG NEWS FROM THE
SECOND CIRCUIT COURT TODAY, WE
HAVE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COUNSEL,
JAY SEKULOW.
ALSO THE CHIEF COUNSEL FOR THAT
CENTER FOR AMERICAN LAW AND
JUSTICE.
SARAH, YOUR OPINION ON THE COURT
RULING?
>> THEY ARE NOW LOOKING AT A
SECOND WHISTLE-BLOWER AND MY
STATEMENT IS, SO WHAT EQUIPMENT
WE RELEASE THE TRANSCRIPT.
IS IT REALLY RELEVANT WHAT SOME
OTHER PERSON WHO MAY OR MAY NOT
HAVE HEARD THE CONVERSATION
THOUGHT ABOUT IT?
THE TRANSCRIPT HAS BEEN
RELEASED.
IT IS OUT THERE IN THE PUBLIC.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY COULDN'T GET RUSSIA, THEY
COULDN'T GET OBSTRUCTION, THEN
IT WAS A QUID PRO QUO WITH
UKRAINE AND A TRANSCRIPT THAT
SHOWED NO QUID PRO QUO AND IT
WAS A COVER-UP BUT THERE WAS NO
COVER-UP BECAUSE THE TRANSCRIPT
WAS RELEASED AND IT WAS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, WHAT DID THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER DO?
NO FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE FOR MOST
OF IT AND DIDN'T BOTHER TO TELL
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH ADAM SCHIFF BECAUSE OF
COURSE ADAM SCHIFF SAID NOBODY,
NONE OF US HAD ANY CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WHICH
ENDED UP OF COURSE NOT BEING
TRUE.
NOW WHAT DO WE HAVE?
A SECOND WHISTLE-BLOWER?
THE TRANSCRIPT OUT, IT SPEAKS
FOR ITSELF.
IT'S NOT AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
PERIOD.
U.S. COURT OF APPEALS FOR THE
SECOND COURT TODAY RECOGNIZED --
I WANT TO READ -- I LIKE READING
THE EXACT WORDS OF THE ORDER.
THE CASE IS, DONALD J. TRUMP
VERSUS CYRUS VANCE WHO IS THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY FOR THE COUNTY
OF NEW YORK.
WE FILED A MOTION FOR TEMPORARY
STAYING THE ENFORCEMENT OF
SUBPOENA THAT WAS GIVEN TO THE
PRESIDENT'S ACCOUNTANTS.
WHAT DO THEY WANT TO PLACE MY
TAX RETURNS.
WHAT THEY WANT IN CALIFORNIA
EQUIPMENT TAX RETURNS.
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR OFFICE.
THE HOUSE EXTENDING THEIR
INVESTIGATION THROUGH A LOCAL
D.A.
THE WORDS OF THE SUBPOENA
VERBATIM, THE WORDS OF THE HOUSE
SUBPOENA.
VERBATIM.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
WE GO TO THE SECOND CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS AND THE ISSUE
THIS ORDER.
IT IS HEREBY ORDERED A TEMPORARY
ADMINISTRATIVE STATE IS GRANTED
PENDING EXPEDITED REVIEW BY A
PANEL OF THE COURT, A SCHEDULING
ORDER WHEEL ISSUE IN THE
ORDINARY COURSE FOR THE COURT
ALSO SAID BECAUSE THE UNIQUE
ISSUES RAISED BY THIS APPEAL,
THOSE UNIQUE ISSUES, SEAN,
REALLY, AT THE HEART OF IT, IS
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
AND WHETHER I'M WEARING MY HAT
AS A PRESIDENT'S LAWYER OR CHIEF
COUNSEL OF THE AMERICAN CENTER
FOR LAW AND JUSTICE, YOU HAVE TO
PROTECT THE COMPETITION.
THAT DOESN'T PROTECT A
PRESIDENT, THAT PROTECTS ALL OF
US.
>> Sean: JAY, IT'S A
POST-CONSTITUTIONAL AMERICA.
THE GREAT ONE MARK LEVIN SAID
IT.
THEY WANT TO STACK THE COURTS,
GET RID OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, AND FOR THREE YEARS, NO
EVIDENCE OF ANYTHING AND SAME
LIARS, SAME CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, THE SAME THING WE'VE
HAD FOR THREE YEARS IN THE
COUNTRY.
>> SHONE FROM WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE IS TRY TO WEAPONIZE THE
EXECUTION OF THE CONSTITUTION
FOR THE PRESIDENT IS EXERCISING
HIS AUTHORITY UNDER ARTICLE TWO
MOTHER TRY TO MAKE THAT SOME OF
INAPPROPRIATE ACT.
I THINK THIS IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
GOES NOWHERE.
>> Sean: CALLED THE VOTE.
CALL THE ROLL.
I WANT THEM ALL TO VOTE.
>> THEY AREN'T DOING IT NOW THIS
WEEK OR NEXT.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
DO IT.
>> Sean: I HOPE THEY DO.
THERE THEM.
DO IT.